welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
today we have a very special episode
because i am joined by
three temporary guest co-hosts they are
greg knuckles dr eric helms and dr mike
zordos and
this is not a random assembly of guests
collectively
the four of us are the authors of the
mass research review which stands for
monthly applications
in strengthsport the first day of every
month we put out 10 pieces of content
this includes articles videos and audio
roundtable discussions
and we basically provide concise and
applicable
breakdowns of the latest strength
physique and nutrition research
so we break down the research but
arguably more importantly we discuss
how to apply it for yourself or for your
clients
if you've been thinking about
subscribing to mass we figured we should
probably let you know that we are
currently running our big annual
charity sale which is our biggest sale
of the year so these are the lowest
prices that you're ever going to see for
mass subscriptions
our monthly subscriptions are typically
29 per month during the sale they're all
the way down
at 21 per month and we also have huge
discounts on our annual subscriptions
and our lifetime
subscriptions if you subscribe to mass
during the sale a hundred percent of
your first monthly subscription payment
or twenty one dollars per subscriber for
new annual and lifetime subscriptions
will go to the american foundation for
suicide prevention
this is a really important organization
dedicated to saving lives and bringing
hope to those affected by suicide
and we are really excited to be raising
funds for them this year
finally i will note that today we are
going to discuss a bunch of mass
articles about recent research
in today's episode if you want to read
greg's review
about myonuclear accretion or my review
about vitamin d supplementation and
strength
those articles are now freely available
over at strongerbyscience.com
okay with all that out of the way let's
meet the mass authors and dive into some
research
so first of all dr mike zordos thank you
for joining us today how are you doing
i'm doing great thanks for having me on
how are you doing trex i'm doing well
uh now for some of our listeners who
aren't familiar with you
and your background do you mind giving
us a a quick biographical statement what
who you are and what you're all about of
course um
i'm five foot five inches tall i'm still
growing which is nice to
nice to know i am an associate professor
at florida atlantic university which is
in boca raton florida
and was fortunate enough to hook up with
you guys in 2017 to be able to create
mass
so my research focuses on resistance
training
in healthy people and in disease
populations for strength and
muscle growth adaptations awesome and
people who aren't
mass subscribers still have probably
seen your name because your lab puts out
a lot of really solid research in our
area
now we're also joined by the good doctor
eric helms
and there's a nasty rumor out there that
he and i are the same person so
one of the reasons we've had you on the
show before but that didn't really seem
to dispel those rumors at all but we
think maybe a second round might do it
so dr helms for those who don't know you
uh
how about a quick bio absolutely well
it's a pleasure to be
back on and still not being you i'm sure
it is great to be you
eric um but i suppose
no yeah okay well fair enough well then
i am i'm a lucky eric
um so yeah like like you said my name is
eric and uh
most relevant stuff i am the 2019 second
place middleweight finisher at the uh
inbf muscle mayhem um i'm six foot
and i'm not growing i'm not getting
taller uh like cerdos but i absolutely
am
growing in bicep size i've been up about
quarter millimeter in the last couple
years so i expect that to continue that
trajectory
but i am down here in new zealand
at the auckland university of technology
i am a researcher at sports performance
research institute new zealand
where i do research specifically looking
at strength and physique sport with my
lovely doctoral and master's students
and
i'm also chief science officer and one
of the co-founders of 3d muscle journey
where we coach drug-free strength and
physique athletes of all levels
competitive non-competitive i write
stuff
and generally i'm just far too obsessed
with bodybuilding and
strength sport but that's why i'm here i
guess right
yeah and you kind of sold yourself short
there so you mentioned your
uh bodybuilding credential but lately
you've been competing in
everything that could even loosely be
associated with strength sports so
you've been doing the bodybuilding and
uh weightlifting and strongman and
powerlifting and i think you have a big
thumb wrestling tournament coming up in
a couple weeks is that correct
yes uh you know one two three four
i declare a thumb war is something that
i've
yeah i mean we're we're pacifists but
it's a very competitive environment here
um we don't mess around um you know the
saying is she'll be right
uh until you get in the thumb war ring
and that's when
things go wrong for everybody and we
walk around with a lot fewer thumbs
afterwards
so awesome well we'll have to bring you
back on and
get a run down have that of how that
tournament went but
for today's episode what we really want
to do actually can i butt in
sure so there's obviously an elephant in
the room i'm just gonna say what we're
all thinking
helms clearly got robbed at the inbf
muscle mayhem show he should have won
far too many of the judges mailed in the
ballots
uh you know i think there wasn't
sufficient oversight
helms's side they didn't allow enough uh
observers in the room when they were
counting those ballots
uh we need a very robust stop the steel
campaign
to reinstate eric helms as the rightful
winner
of imbf muscle mayhem i also noticed a
lot of those judges cards
were filled out with black ink and
signed with blue ink
so i don't know how that works how does
that happen well and all of the pro
helms
judges uh used sharpie which uh i think
that may have gotten some of their
ballots invalidated
how do you feel about that helms well
you know i
i think that all legal votes should be
counted let me just come out and say
that
and you know there there are some rumors
going around
uh that the winner of the middleweight
class uh adam mcdonald
that he was actually a 3dmj athlete uh
coached by
jeff alberts and then after that he went
on to win
the national title title in ireland um
trying to paint him
in some picture as as part of 3dmj i
mean technically he is
and still is uh and and technically he
did win that national title showing his
his uh bona fides as an amateur
bodybuilder but but look at it this way
like
if you have to have votes counted after
prejudging to win uh which allegedly
uh i've heard i don't have any evidence
to to prove that but that's what i've
heard
um i've got some youtube videos i can
send you then then really does that
validate or invalidate uh that win or
your bona fides so wait is he is he
irish
yes he is would you say there may have
been some foreign
interference in that show then
[Laughter]
that's uh yes absolutely that's that's
that's a good point that i that i hadn't
considered i need to
i'll have to set up a press conference
to talk about that maybe in front of
some type of
you know random shop in an industrial
sector or something like that
all i'm saying is that by january 20th
it's going to be clear that you won that
show and
the deep state of natural bodybuilding
will be exposed
yep that's certainly one perspective
yeah
absolutely all right so with today's
episode
uh one of the reasons we're excited to
have all the mass
research reviewers on is because we want
to have a nice
recap of volume four of mass so
volume four it comes out every single
month the first day of the month volume
four was all of the year two
uh 2020. a lot of people are saying the
best year on record
just across the board so it was also a
great year for mass
we had a lot of really good issues and
we wanted to kind of go through the
highlights and have each author talk
about some of their favorite work
that they published in mass in the year
2020 so
dr helms i want to start with you we've
already talked about some of the
controversies in bodybuilding you had a
really good article
that was actually bodybuilding research
which is
unfortunately really hard to do and as a
result pretty rare
in the literature so you covered a study
that looked at the first bodybuilding
style refeed
research so why don't you give us a
little rundown of what they found but
also just kind of what it means
in the broader sense absolutely yeah so
um
this came out of the good doctor bill
campbell's lab
and eric i know you've done some some
work with them um
and i know dr campbell he does great
work it's it's been really cool to see
him and his lab produce a lot of very
like you said bodybuilding relevant
research um so they came out with
the first i would argue probably like
truly representative ecologically valid
refeed style research so most of what we
have
in the the realm of non-linear dieting
if you will
or what is typically called intermittent
energy restriction has set ups that
aren't really used in at least in our
little circle
of strength and physique sport as ways
to drop weight
this is almost like the reverse of one
of the more common things if you've ever
heard of the five and two diet
that's actually where you have uh five
days
at roughly maintenance and then two days
that are very very very low calorie
intake sometimes just like a protein
shake and sometimes
24 hour fasting so that's the type of
research that's out there
uh this is a the opposite of that like i
said like a five and two diet where
instead
you've got two days uh that are in uh
that are at maintenance
and then five days that are at a
moderate or moderately high deficit
this is a very kind of standard approach
that you've seen in the last few years
in bodybuilding circles
where you'll have you know four or five
days of dieting and then a handful of
days as quote unquote refeeds
i would say you know more popularly and
we talked about this in our review paper
eric about
uh natural bodybuilding is that you'll
see like cheat meals traditionally
or cheat days and i think those have
transitioned to becoming say
you know refeeds and i'd say since the
early to mid 2000s like
coaches like dr joe klemzewski and lane
norton and
us at 3dmj we've we've said hey you know
the goal isn't to
have a day where you get to cheat on
your diet but rather we need to think
about some of the potential benefits
of bringing calories up and a lot of
that was based on
you know mechanistic research animal
data and kind of extrapolating from some
of the few
trials on intermittent energy
restriction
uh in individuals with obesity or in
clinical populations or even sometimes
you know normal weight people who are
not resistance training
and trying to see you know how can we
get a benefit from this so
uh this is a really cool study because
like you said it was
a pretty long study it was a seven week
period and they had
resistance-trained individuals who were
at a pretty
i'd say quote-unquote like normal body
fat percentage uh
and they were you know not you know
relatively lean people trying to get
leaner
and they used a pretty standard setup
one had a continuous energy restriction
on the other group every after five days
of dieting
they would have two days of maintenance
they matched the total
uh energy restriction between groups so
they had like a 25 percent
caloric restriction in the continuous
group
35 percent in the refeed group
so net over time they were trying to
match energy they kept resistance
training throughout
and they measured changes in body
composition
they used i think what is a novel
technique i haven't seen it before where
they tried to
account for any differences in body
water between groups so they calculated
dry fat free mass
by combining their body comp
measurements with i think bia to assess
uh body water um and changes in rmr as
well to see if there's an impact on
resting
metabolic rate and you know basically
the findings were pretty straightforward
you saw non-significant differences
between groups
in fat mass and fat-free mass and
rmr but there were significant
reductions
in in fat-free mass from pre to post
in the non-refeed group and there were
non-significant and significant
reductions in rmr but there were
non-significant reductions in fat free
mass and rmr
in the refeed group and probably the the
most important aspect of it
there was one between group difference
and that was that
less dry free dry fat free mass was lost
in the refeed group
so on balance you know this is the first
study of its kind
it's not like a huge sample size and
certainly you know not without
limitations but it does
absolutely lean in the uh the direction
of refuse being beneficial
uh for for maintaining more lean body
mass um
so i think i'll leave it there that's
the general summary and of course if
you've got questions i mean there are
some limitations it's been out for a
while i think this came out back in
you know march or april if i recall
correctly and
you know it's been it's been discussed
some people have
noted certain limitations but i know
eric you're pretty familiar with the
data as well so i'll leave it there and
see where we want to go with it
yeah i mean i i guess it we might as
well acknowledge what some of the
main limitations are that people have
pointed out you know there's the easy
stuff there's the sample size
right but one of the things that a lot
of people pointed
out is uh you know some of the changes
were not significant between groups so
like you mentioned dry fat free mass
was but when they looked at the uh
typical fat free mass value
unadjusted for for body water and when
they looked at resting metabolic rate
they found uh you know something that
was significant in one group
but not in the other which is
informative but it's not the same
as a between group difference so after
seeing some
of the conversation unfold
in the evidence-based fitness world do
you feel any differently about
the main takeaways from it do you still
see these kind of two-day refeeds as
being
a reasonably justifiable approach for
you know i kind of
unintentionally implied that the the
subjects were physique athletes
they were not i'm sure some of them
probably were but you know this was just
kind of
probably the the typical listener to the
podcast you know a person who
might not be a competitive physique
athlete but generally is interested in
some
you know resistance training to get
stronger change their body composition
maybe stay on the leaner side so
we don't have a lot of good research
from
people who are not a clinical population
who are trying to go from kinda lean to
leaner
with resistance training so it's a good
pop
a good sample for you know who usually
actually utilizes this kind of research
so for those people
do you still think a two-day refeed is
justifiable
yeah i do i think it's um it's hard to
look at this data
and just dismiss uh some of those you
know
within versus between group differences
as purely
you know that's just the data was small
sample size we need longer
um you know when you see a between group
difference
in in one metric that goes in the same
direction
as the within group stuff like now
granted if
let's say the dry fat-free mass was was
leaning in favor of the refeed group
but all the other metrics going the
other way that my first thought would be
you know this is kind of an untested
metric
i'm not sure of the validity of using
this method of
assessing quote-unquote dry fat-free
mass it's not even going the same
direction
as fat-free mass this must be a water
thing and this didn't account for it
but the fact of the matter is that
everything kind of makes sense you know
and and it
it passes the logic test you know if if
rmr was impacted
uh we both know that probably the
biggest thing that's going to impact rmr
is your fat free mass
so if there was a you know within group
difference leaning in the direction of
more fat free mass retained
subsequently greater rmr retained and we
see a between group difference
with dry fat free mass i think that that
that tells you like ah you know this is
it
very least it's absolutely not worse and
if anything i would say
uh the data leans in the direction of
refeeds being helpful
one other limitation i think is worth
bringing up and
you know this is pitched as a
delimitation by the authors
in that they waited two days after the
refeed to assess
changes in the refeed group to make sure
that there wasn't
you know impact from glycogen and you
know intramuscular water and things like
that on the findings
but the question is and i know i've
heard some people bring this up
well what happened in those two days
could they have done something with
their diet that would have you know
caused those
those changes and i i struggle with that
because
it's basically the same argument you'd
have as if they were
measured right after the refeed you know
if they were eating more food than the
other group
they could have maintained more muscle
well that's the whole reason we waited
until after the refeed you know they
weren't given an
intervention or an instruction but you
know the other group
where they measured immediately after
it's not 100
clear so i think uh i think that that's
probably the the fairest
uh you know critique is hey we don't
really know what what happened
uh in in those two periods although
there's two days that period where
uh the group that was refeeding was
asked to to hopefully wash out the
effect
of the refeeds um so you know it's
possible
that that somehow had an impact but i
would think that the fact that they're
assessing dry fat free mass are trying
to account for water
and that we're seeing these rmr changes
um
i don't think a lot of that would be
impacted by acute feeding
that much so nonetheless i i think
absolutely there's it's
totally justifiable to to do refeeds um
you know worst case scenario you know we
just have some funkiness going on
with with the uh the way the data was
collected in this and it biased
uh to show a benefit towards the refeed
group but i absolutely don't think it's
masking like a negative effect
uh by any means yeah i mean looking at
the values you know
the continuous group lost 1.3 kilograms
of fat free mass the refeed group only
0.4 looking at dry fat free mass
negative 1.9 in the continuous group and
then only
negative 0.2 in the refeed group
and then the the drop in resting
metabolic rate 78 calories in the
continuous group and only 38 in the
refeed group and so when you triangulate
those they all
seem to lean in the same direction and
of course it you know
those criticisms of the study are fair
and valid so this is the type of thing
where
two very reasonable informed people can
just
walk away with different conclusions
based on how much weight they want to
put into the data from this study
but um my question is
you know when you get really rigid about
finding
a low p value for that between group
comparison and
you're like no it's got to be
statistically significant
my question is how big did you expect
this effect to be
you know i mean like when we're talking
about just shifting the same total
number of calories to a couple different
days throughout the week
i mean are you really expecting in small
sample research like this that we're
gonna see
three four five kilograms of lean mass
preservation so
i i think even though that between group
comparison wasn't statistically
significant like you said
when you look at it face value at least
leans in that direction
and because of the lack of significance
i i think you can have some
some very reasonable back and forth and
and two informed people can walk away
with a different interpretation of the
data but i think you and i see it pretty
much eye to eye
um you know i i think it's a modest
benefit leaning in favor of those
refeeds
will future research pan out the exact
same way who knows
but uh i know i'd certainly like to see
it i'm sure you feel the same
yeah absolutely i think i think there
are i think
there's almost a meta discussion here as
to what is a reasonable way to interpret
data
and i think i think if we want to do
this
appropriately you know even entering the
conversation let's say
we've got two people who are ones a
little more conservative in their
analysis
one is uh you know more liberal if you
will
as soon as we enter this conversation
we're both acknowledging this is the
first study that exists
it has small sample sizes and
therefore there's already the ceiling
comes far
down on how excited we can get about
this i think
anything beyond saying oh that's cool
maybe refeeds
are something you know it's not just the
the anecdotes of bodybuilders which
which we have
we've actually seen there's a study by
mitchell where qualitatively
uh a lot of bodybuilders were
interviewed and said hey refeed seemed
to work really well for me
okay so it's beyond anecdotes there's
something leaning in that direction
would be cool to see more research i
think that's about as positive
you can get and given bodybuilders are
already doing this coaches are already
doing this
uh we're not going to go like hey by the
way everyone you need to stop now until
we have study two
you know like i don't think anyone's
saying that uh but i think the
conservative version is also quite
reasonable like
you know we only saw this this one kind
of semi-exploratory non-validated metric
of fat-free mass
that was truly significant between
groups you know
we need more research i think what you
can't say is
this is amazing everyone should be doing
refeeds it's going to preserve all your
muscle mass and you also can't say
this study was was horrendously flawed
and you know this this is a method that
we can't know they waited two days and
and i know for sure
that this is just you know water weight
masking masking changes
um so in my opinion so long as you're
not in any one of those extremes
you're completely within the realm of a
reasonable interpretation of the data
but in either case it doesn't take
refeeds off the table or put them on
some kind of pedestal
definitely you know i i think since you
just kind of like
cracked the door open to the anecdote
zone we need to go ahead and step all
the way through
one of my criticisms of this study was
that the refeed period was relatively
short
in follow-up work what i'd like to see
discussed is
refeeds lasting months to years so for
me personally i've been refeeding
for about the last six years and i gotta
say it's going great
uh lean mass fine uh metabolic furnace
burning as hot as can be conceived of
uh so that's how i personally feel about
the whole refeed thing
uh and honestly i think scientists are a
bunch of cowards for nada for not
looking into
that way to implement refeeds so
a little bit of pushback i think
technically six years would be more of a
diet break than a refund
in most the working definition that most
people have adopted
um but who knows maybe they'll look into
that next do the matador
study six years of dieting six years of
a diet break
on and off for 40 years or something
now shifting gears a little bit mike
one of the one of the topics we speak
about a lot in the podcast
is the interference effect we've got a
lot of listeners who do
some combination of resistance training
and some type of cardiovascular training
and there's always some degree of
concern about
how to make those fit together uh within
a program and whether or not
the interference effect is something
that should be worried about so
uh in volume four of mass you had a
great article
about the interference effect so why
don't you take it away and give us a
little rundown
yeah thanks i'm i'm glad to hear this is
something that you guys talk about quite
a bit
uh i mean that i listen to every episode
and i
i i know you talk about all the time
and uh this has been uh this has
actually been a topic of interest of
mine
uh for about 12 years it was the first
research topic that i was really ever
interested in
and one of the reasons that i wanted to
go on and continue education
many years ago so concurrent training is
something that i really enjoy talking
about really enjoy writing about and
just learning about
so before i get into the study just
briefly
trucks you mentioned that there are some
listeners that you know might have some
level of concern about including aerobic
exercise
with their resistance training and that
may attenuate hypertrophy or
strength adaptations and that's
certainly a very valid concern
and what i hope to illustrate in the
next few minutes after talking about the
study briefly and then giving a more
overall depiction of the concurrent
training literature
is that while those concerns are not
invalid
you and you will run into a point where
there's this
inevitable point where you have to kind
of
manage them a little bit and you might
see all right i i'm going to have to
break some of the scientific rules a
little bit to get in enough cardio if
i'm dieting for a bodybuilding show or
something like that
however you can mitigate
greatly the negative risk of cardio
on these anaerobic adaptations as long
as we go about things in a logical
manner
so with that said let's talk about this
study and then get back to that
term logical manner when implementing
concurrent training
so the study that we looked at here
and that i reviewed which by the way is
one of the best titles i believe i've
ever come up with in mass and i was very
very pleased to come up with this title
not my best but one of the best
and in this title and in this article
there was a study that was done it was
on members of the danish military
and that's important because these
members of the danish military
in addition to the program that i'm
going to outline for you in the study
they were doing hours of extra exercise
and cardio
and endurance training just in addition
to the what i'm going to lay out here
but
the important findings are they still
while there were no difference between
the three groups i'm going to lay out
they still got stronger in general and
they still got bigger in general
so the three groups in the study of
these danish military members going
through a basic training phase in the
military
they had one of the groups which did two
hours per week
of running and strength training now
these two hours per week were broken up
into two days
and they were done in what they called
micro sessions so 15 minutes of strength
training here
15 minutes of running here and the
running
and lifting that were done on the same
day were always separated by two hours
and an amounted to 60 minutes of lifting
per week and 60 minutes of running per
week but in these 15 minute blocks
another group did in one session 30
minutes of running
and 30 minutes of lifting and they did
that twice per week
so running and lifting together that
amounted to an hour
and then another group did 60 minutes of
lifting one day and then essentially 60
minutes of running one day
so all of that amounted to the same time
but the sessions as you can see from
that that's not a lot of lifting and
there was maybe five six sets of the
main exercises per week
and the endurance exercise was running
it wasn't cycling it wasn't something
low impact it was running
in general strength increased on a
variety of exercises
maximal voluntary contraction pull-ups
things like that
and they did that not only with the low
volume of resistance training they were
doing
but again with the hours of extra basic
training that they were doing
so no differences between groups here
but the takeaway from this
that i like to portray is that i'm not
telling you to go
and lift weights in this manner if your
main goals are strength and hypertrophy
in fact you shouldn't you're going to
need more volume you're not going to
want to do anywhere close to this type
of aerobic training
but i think it does help to demonstrate
a point that these individuals got
stronger
they tended to get bigger so
if you're someone who thinks hey i'm
going to do a couple sessions of cardio
or i'm going to run once or twice and oh
my god it's all over
then that's not the case right this is
good news that oh wow
that isn't going to necessarily crush
all of my gains if you will
now on the other side of it it's not to
say it didn't interfere at all
we can't technically conclude if there's
an interference effect here because
there was no group that just lifted
weights
but we do have enough other evidence to
know
or to suggest pretty strongly if there
was a group that did only lift weights
they would have better adaptations than
all these others so to use that term
interference effect now as we go to the
more broad discretion
discussion which is what treks use is to
say
that term interference effect comes from
the fact that
if you lift weights and then in general
if you add in some type of
long duration aerobic exercise i'm not
talking about sprinting
i'm just giving a long duration steady
state cardio for a long period of time
and you add that into your lifting the
your strength and hypertrophy and power
should then be
attenuated or the rate of increase
should be lower
and that comes from a meta-analysis that
was published almost 10 years ago now
and some a few follow-ups since then
that principle is pretty well
established but
the most important thing and i use the
term kind of the
logic earlier or implementing things in
a logical manner
is when we talk about these old studies
that are done on concurrent training
they are designed to show the
interference effect
so the first study from hixson in 1980
showed the interference effect i think
helms was there for that data collection
you might have been a subject
and so in that study
hixon had three groups they had a group
over 10 weeks that only did endurance
training
had a group that did strength training
lifted weights five days per week
and a group that did endurance and then
a group that did concurrent training
which simply lifted weights five days
per week and did endurance training six
days per week
now that study showed that the there was
about half the increase in strength and
hypertrophy
in the group that did concurrent
training versus the group that did
strength training
over the 10 weeks now in that study the
concurrent and the strength group
actually increased strength hypertrophy
to about the same extent for the first
five or six weeks and it was really the
latter half of the study
where there there was the interference
effect but that's what the interference
effect is is when that aerobic exercise
interferes with
the anaerobic adaptations so but in that
study though when i say studies are
designed
to show the interference effect think
about that one group
lifted weights five days per week and
then the concurrent training group
just did that and and ran and cycled six
days per week on top of it that's
extreme
that's not what most of us are doing
when we're incorporating cardio
we're talking about two days a week here
three days per week here
maybe four days per week as you're
getting more into it some of those
sessions are sprinting and not just
moderate intensity cardio and that type
of thing
so i think it's analogous to if you look
at one of the
early studies that look at static
stretching and performance it shows a
decrease of strength
but individuals held stretches for 100
seconds
right of course that's going to have a
negative effect of course concurrent
training is going to have a negative
effect
if you're adding six days of running on
top of five days of lifting
so i think when we think about things
logically we can start to mitigate
this so some of the things that
meta-analyses and individual studies
have shown is all right
there's this let's say wide gap let's
say you're you're
going to increase strength and
hypertrophy you know
by about a hundred percent more you know
double the gains in
some of these studies um when you have
these you know
intense concurrent training bouts but if
you reduce the duration of that let's
say from
60 minutes of endurance training at a
time to 30 minutes at a time
you reduce the frequency from six days a
week to three days per week
that difference of concurrent training
to strength training alone decreases
really really rapidly there's not that
much difference anymore
then when you say hey i want to choose
cycling instead of running
running has a strong eccentric component
creating a lot of damage
cycling does not a little bit more low
impact the difference between performing
concurrent training and strength
training alone
becomes even lower when we're just
talking about strength and hypertrophy
those things tend to be
less impacted than something like power
adaptations so i think concurrent
training would be more harmful for a
high power athlete
rather than just a power lifter or a
bodybuilder not to mention
the actual benefits that you're getting
from the concurrent training if you're a
bodybuilder that's looking to lean out
or a power lifter
that needs to make a weight class so
when constructing a program logically i
think we can work around
this pretty well there's a few different
kind of hypotheses and mechanisms that
can account for this
but we can avoid this so if you go in if
there's some data and we've collected in
our lab as well
if you're cycling three days per week
for 30 minutes at 50
vo2 max i would i would challenge
anybody and i would say
do you really think that's going to harm
your strength gains
if you squat and deadlift and do lower
body work monday wednesday and friday
and you do that cycling tuesday thursday
and saturday for 30 minutes
at a low intensity or moderate intensity
do you really believe that's going to
harm your strength gains
and i would say that the answer is no
certainly if you start to do that now
for 60 minutes at a time or 90 minutes
at a time
maybe some of that bleeds into it but
when you look at your programming
i think one of the things you can do is
try and program logically
try and keep for the most part the
cardio work 24 hours away
from the lower body strength work don't
do it on the same day don't do it in the
morning and then
then squat later in the day if you have
to put on the same day as lifting
maybe you bench press in the morning and
then you cycle later in the day that
shouldn't be an issue
if you are concerned that let's say you
typically get your cardio in tuesday
thursday saturday and squat monday
wednesday friday
but on friday you have a heavy squat
move that thursday
cardio session over to sunday and then
you get it away from the heavy squat on
friday maybe you have volume squats on
monday
but volume shouldn't be as affected from
30 minutes of
cycling as a heavy squat would be 24
hours later
the point being if you just look at how
to configure your training program
you consider the duration of the cardio
you consider the modality of the cardio
you consider the frequency of the cardio
if you're a bodybuilder let's say or a
power lifter your goal
isn't cardio performance your goal is
the caloric expenditure
your goal is to become leaner from that
so where you can get into trouble with
concurrent training
is if you have dual performance goals
you have a performance goal
in you know you want to train for a 5k
or a longer distance
and you want to train to become the best
power lifter that you can be
unfortunately at some point you're then
going to run into an issue
where you're not going to get the most
out of your ability in one of them and
you'd have to make a choice
but if you don't have performance goals
and you're just doing it for the sake of
hey caloric expenditure and becoming
lean
then you have a lot of leeway to
configure all of those things duration
modality frequency
and where it goes in around your
programming to be able to
to to put that in there the other aspect
to discuss
i would say briefly is a lot of people
especially i don't know maybe 10 10
years ago now
some of you guys may be more up on the
time frame in the bodybuilding community
we're all about hit
and i think hit is still a tool that is
can be used and i'm sure a lot of people
still use it
however i would question the use of a
solely using hit for
for cardio just because if you think of
what takes mentally more energy to do
you you're doing a bunch of sprints for
30 minutes after a long day of work
or you're doing a modern intensity
cycling session
so i think in in those cases while hit
might be ideal or scientifically ideal
it's not always the practical choice not
to mention the muscle damage that might
come along with those sprints if you're
on accustomed to it
and then that could bleed into your
session the next day so
something with cardio too is to always
keep in mind you can use a flexible
template for this
hey i have to get in 12 sessions of
cardio over the next month i want the
client to do four hit sessions
but the rest of them can be moderate
intensity just get them in so i think
there's a lot there there's a lot to
impact there and there's still more to
discuss but
the bottom line is for anybody that is
concerned about this
i think that yes just on paper looking
at the results of a meta-analysis or an
individual study
it looks kind of damning it looks oh my
god
i'm going to be in some serious trouble
if i do some cardio
but when you understand that most of
these studies are designed
to show the interference effect because
they have such an extreme
concurrent training or cardio
intervention if you take all those
factors into account
and program it logically as we stated i
think you'll be just fine
so mike i think you raised some really
good points
that definitely warrant further
discussion but one of the things you
just very briefly mentioned that
uh i definitely think we should get into
that
might have actually come as a pretty big
surprise to a lot of our listeners
is just how old eric helms is
so is is there anything else you'd like
to say about that just to to kind of
expand on that topic
you know it's it's hard greg um at this
point i think we should just go around
the horn here we'll start with with
you greg would you like to reintroduce
yourself to eric because he for
after about 15 minutes his memory goes
if we could
if we could do that you know so um you
know well i guess we can get back to
that portion of the show later
but he's been he's been around for for
quite some time here
you know he was a subject in that study
um
and uh it was it was great to to hear
about that
i he he was telling me once although his
his memory goes but he did tell me a few
years back what it was like watching
babe ruth play he said he was as good as
as
as everybody says these days which was
really great to hear said he was
was a nice guy he's actually thinner
than uh
than you see in the movie if you've
watched the movie that came out in the
90s said he was a bit thinner than that
so
that's good to hear eric are you are you
eric eric
are you still there
so i view helm's does anybody watch
espn college game day when they like
before all the college football games
they make their picks and kind of
preview the games
yeah i view helms as our lee corso
you know we you know his i mean his
reputation speaks for itself
we have to help him along through the
broadcast a little bit from time to time
but
lee to his credit is perfect on his
picks this year
when he picks the winner of the big game
at the end so i think helms is
he's still doing a great job it's just
sometimes we got
support him a little bit well i i really
appreciate the level of self-awareness
he shows how he kind of brands himself
as captain america
because right before our eyes uh as the
ravages of time really just eat away at
him
we're seeing him transition from captain
america the first avenger to
uh steve rogers at the end of in game
right in front of our eyes and and you
know it
gives us some perspective about what
time is going to do to all of us
uh and just the fact that eric is is
showing us
the direction that path takes about 40
years before any of the rest of us are
gonna get there
uh i i really appreciate him for it you
know omar i
i totally agree and i think this is
probably going to be one of our
our best episodes of iron culture um
so yeah i just thanks for having me on
uh on sigma nutrition radio danny i
appreciate that
no no so so mike actual serious question
uh and mostly i'm just kicking this over
to you because
uh probably half a dozen people have
asked it on the q a form
for the stronger by science podcast and
i don't care about it enough to attempt
to answer it
and i think you might actually be able
to answer it pretty well
so uh thus far we've been talking about
people whose primary goal is lifting and
they want to add some cardio in either
just to burn some calories to get in
better shape to feel better whatever
several people have asked though like
okay my primary goal is running and i
want to start doing some lifting
uh you know to build some muscle get a
little bit stronger but primarily with a
goal
of supporting my cardiovascular training
and being able to run faster bike faster
and farther etc so kind of from
the opposite perspective how would you
go about setting up training for someone
who primarily has cardiovascular goals
but does also want to do some lifting as
well
yeah i actually uh am very interested in
in answering this question so
from the other side of it and it's a
it's a really good point just because
in this world in the lifting world if
you will
we whenever we hear the term concurrent
training we automatically
you know people get scared go ah you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna get weak and
that's the reaction
i think they they do that too i could do
it again i think greg's laughing at me
right now but they go ah
just like that the fear is palpable
it is and um so i can see helm's looking
over the shoulder i think the access van
is coming to pick him up right now
take him
and so in this world that's kind of our
reaction but
in the aerobic exercise world when you
hear concurrent training
remember the immediate thought would be
the opposite which is
now i'm incorporating lifting for my
running what impact is this going to
have
and what's funny is it's when we think
of it in the lifting world too
we're always thinking of it not because
anybody has any interest in
running performance or cycling
performance but because how can this
i can how can i use this as a tool to
make me leaner and
in the running world nobody's thinking
of it for any reason other than
how can i lift weights to make me faster
and
so they're always thinking about lifting
from helping them from a performance
perspective
and so in that way i think it's a really
interesting
kind of way to view it but so
the data is very clear that resistance
training can be extraordinarily helpful
for running performance
the only real physiological downside to
lifting weights for running
is if you're lifting weights let's say
like a bodybuilder
and you're putting on too much muscle
mass and this is you know causing you to
carry more weight that's certainly going
to be a negative
certainly after a certain point for
running performance but for runners the
data is very clear
that resistance training can help
running performance but again the
resistance training
should be as specific as it can be for
those runners so when people hear that
term resistance training
they think sometimes they're lifting oh
man i don't want to get big
so the basic guidelines something like
two to three times a week for runners
keeping the exercises certainly mostly
focused on the lower body doesn't mean
you shouldn't be neglecting the upper
body but mostly focused on the lower
body
that are a mix of explosive
but also it's okay and this is what i
think some runners miss on this
they think oh i don't want to lift too
heavy so i'm going to perform
you know 8 10 12 15 reps and stay a
fusion drop shy of failure well now
you're doing hypertrophy training
so this should probably be things like
split squats
and the sets of four five
six things like that maybe a couple reps
shy of failure
you're not doing too much volume um a
lot of
super sets in there not necessarily for
the cardiovascular benefit because
you're getting that but just from a time
efficiency perspective
because if you're doing something like a
split squat you can do some sort of core
work at the same time while you're doing
that
you've probably already run depending on
the uh
what you're training for 8 10 12 15
miles for some of these runners early in
the morning
and then you're getting in 30 45 minutes
of resistance training two three times a
week a week later in the day
so it's a mix of explosive resistance
training and heavier resistance training
avoiding the high volume work um
split squats some step ups even squats
with the barbell goblet squats are okay
as well
front squats are used a lot in the
running community as well
even deadlifts things from the floor the
exercise selection can be
kind of similar although i would make
sure to get some sort of unilateral work
in there i think that's important
but it's okay to do those bilateral
movements as well um keeping those reps
kind of low a couple times a week
easy way to mix in core work whether
it's
you know planks whether it's you know
holding in a crunch position
uh uh you know with weights for a while
some isometric core
work that a lot of runners do a lot of
extra hamstring work that runners will
do as well
one leg rdls are a common exercise uh
so all those things can be mixed in
there but resistance training is very
helpful for runners there's a couple met
analyses on this systematic reviews
and a bunch of original research that
really started coming out about 15 years
ago
helps improve stride length running
economy maintenance of stride length
throughout the length of
a 5k and one really good study where
they used some motion capture to look at
stride length
improve running times and some pretty
good runners so
my recommendations couple times a week
not high volume
keeping the the sessions relatively
short overall keeping it explosive
and keeping the weights pretty low
mixing in some unilateral work
and and just again just kind of like the
other concurrent training
configuring it so if you have a long run
or you have what runners would call a
workout or a speed work the next day
you know you're not doing something too
damaging the day before that a lot of
distance runners most of their work is
actually what they call easy running
and so you would perform it a day before
that or on an easy running day which
would make it a bit easier to be
prepared for the long run
so relatively low volume heavy stuff
explosive stuff
get your lu your unilateral work in and
just make sure it doesn't come right
before one of your your faster workouts
absolutely zordos before we move on to
another topic i do have two really quick
follow-up questions
um the first one what about modality
um on my instagram somebody posted a
question about this my instagram by the
way is blowing up
i mean it's it's mental over there
people are saying that some of my
content is too hot for instagram
actually omar has been saying that a lot
i'm starting to get worried about it
that they're going to be shutting me
down soon but over on the instagram
someone asked
where does rowing fit in and like how do
you when we talk about
making that cardio choice based on the
interference effect
running cycling rowing how do those
factor in i think it's a great question
so i'm going to
first give a response that's not going
to be super helpful
at least not today but i hope down the
road it is it's mainly the response that
i usually give my students in class when
when they ask this question because this
is a very common question and
one that i should have addressed which
is if you
understand this conceptually then
think about the recommendations we gave
between running and cycling
think what rowing is more similar to
and then how that might affect things so
so my first part of that is to say hey
think conceptually and then we can kind
of break this down and understand it but
to give a more direct answer that will
be more helpful
is first of all if you row
now you let's say you jump on a rowing
machine at the gym
this is mostly your upper body working
so now instead of your lower body being
affected
now you have to configure this around
your upper body training
because again the modality of
cardio only matters in that you want to
choose the one that's
least likely to negatively affect your
strength and size
so rowing might fit a bit with cycling
and we think of that there isn't
necessarily going to be the impact
now if you're depending on how much
resistance that you put on you might see
some of this but again with the imp
with the resistance on rowing you're
getting that resistance on the
concentric portion
and not as much on the eccentric portion
so you're not getting as much
damage as let's say running would so
while rowing might fit more along the
lines of something like
cycling the difference is that rowing is
going to affect the upper body
so the recommendations that we gave
earlier for how to fit the cycling in
around
the squat let's say we said tuesday
thursday saturday you're cycling monday
wednesday friday you're squatting
in this case we might say tuesday
thursday saturday you're rowing
monday wednesday friday you are benching
perfect and
i did have another follow-up question um
i'm pretty sure you correct me if i'm
wrong guys i'm pretty sure zordo spent
a great deal of time uh
kind of bragging about the title to his
article did you ever actually say the
title
i'm pretty sure you just mentioned how
great it was and blew right by it it's
it's a it's what they call a teaser
eric and so now to get the title
they will need to subscribe to mouse so
perhaps man that's that's good marketing
that's good stuff it is you said your
instagram is blowing up
have you seen mine i actually haven't i
i don't think anyone's seen your
instagram
that's that's because they already shut
it down unlike trexus
yeah well you have to compete with my
titles i had one that was
shedding some light on vitamin d that
was
i mean that people were going wild over
that yours
um the cherry and it had uh i had sweet
in the title toward the end yep
that was that was cherries sweet effects
on recovery
i had uh capsaicin the
hottest supplement on the market i mean
i i think you might have oversold your
title a little bit can i submit
i i personally think the best and and
not to flex too hard here
was mine that was uh splish splash i was
taking a salty bath to get weight was i
wasting my time
that was that was that was excellent
hold on okay i
i need to shut the whole the whole this
whole thing down because
before trexler even joined yeah uh i was
strongly pushing for mass's title itself
to just simply be applications and
strength sport
applications and strength sport because
i think it gives us more flexibility
when we release
these guys were too afraid of the
acronym that would follow that
i i wasn't i didn't blink in the face of
controversy
so let's just say you got your titles of
of these articles
i had a title for mass that would have
broke the internet
no that would have been it would have
been a branding issue with me
it would have caused confusion uh my my
preferred metric
for normalized strength scaling instead
of wilkes score
is alimetrically scaled strength so i've
been talking about the ass coefficient
for years
uh and if i put out a product that was
also called
ass uh one i'm afraid people would get
confused
two i'm afraid brett contreras would sue
me uh
and i just didn't want that smoke
personally may i submit
for consideration um we out here talking
about practice man
that was a pretty good title that was a
good one that that's
that's my i feel that's my runaway
winner for myself
anytime you're bringing alan iverson
into the equation you're gonna be
feeling good about your position listen
trex i don't know no
two-time mvp to come off the bench i
don't know
you know five-time all-star to come off
the bench no first time seven-time
first-time all
first-team all-nba to come off the bench
this is another great one by him
what was most impressive to me is that
he knew all those stats
i was like i don't know any most time
players they're like i don't know i was
first team all nba
he knew all the stats and he was just
toasting larry brown about coming off
the bench and uh
you know but to his to to his point i
also don't know anybody else who has a
seven time first team all nba that comes
off the bench
uh i i think uh alonzo morning did
pretty late in his career
when he was with miami yeah i just enjoy
the
uh zoe lj teams back in charlotte those
were the days
honestly with uh with mugsy bogues in
the mix as well
i was a good nba jam team as well dude
so
we might have to cut this i don't know
if the language here is pc
uh but have you heard the story about
how michael jordan completely ruined
mugsy bogue's three-point shot
no did he do it on the set of space jam
no he did it in a playoff game so can
you
censor the the questionable language uh
make it a more pc version i mean not
really because i don't want to be as
funny that would take all the fun out of
it
it would also reduce the editing time
and lead to fewer
continuity issues as the person who
edits the audio
okay whatever i'll i'll give it a shot
so anyway
mugsy bogues was a basically average
three-point shooter through much of his
career
and then charlotte was in the playoffs
one time they ran into jordan's bulls
uh and relatively late in a game i think
the bulls were either up two or three
and mugsy had a chance to shoot a three
either to tie the game or to pull ahead
uh and the closest defender to him was
michael jordan
and he he would have had like a 10 12
foot closeout
but instead of trying to contest the
shot at all
he just stares down mugsy and just
yells at him shoot it you and uh
mugsy completely airballs it and was a
very below three
below average three-point shooter the
entire rest of his career
like it just completely broke his psyche
which not necessarily condoning the
language
that michael jordan used there could be
seen as discriminatory against short
people
which i know zordos is very sensitive
about
but just the fact that some in-game
trash talk completely changed the
statistical profile of
a professional athlete for the entire
rest of their career
that's that's elite [ __ ] talking
all right i think that's a great way to
transition into
our next topic um i love how you just
served us right into that easy segue
greg that was terrific um so greg
let's talk myonuclear domain theory um
building off our previous comments uh
so you have this is something we've
talked about on the podcast we had uh
alex coliari turner on who's done some
research in this area
uh some really fascinating stuff but uh
in volume four of mass you reviewed a
study about myonuclear
domain theory and muscle memory so why
don't you give us a rundown
of what the study looked at yeah so the
the title of the study i looked at was
the concept of muscle memory evidence
from animal and human studies
by snyder's and colleagues and so
basically this was looking at
what's called myonuclei facilitated
muscle memory
and so the the basic model of this is
that hypertrophy occurs
as muscle hypertrophy occurs myonuclei
are added to the muscle
and then when muscle atrophy occurs all
myonuclei
are retained and so that's called
myonuclear permanence
and then upon retraining since all of
those myonuclei are still there
myonuclear density is higher and that
increases
translational capacity or in other words
basically per unit of volume
for each muscle fiber more muscle
protein can be synthesized leading to
faster hypertrophy
and basically under this model rapid
hypertrophy would slow back down
when you reach your maximum myonuclear
domain
size which should roughly correspond to
your all-time biggest so
essentially muscle memory is being
accomplished by having the the myonuclei
there to preserve
translational capacity so when you start
lifting again
you can basically get back to your
all-time biggest relatively quickly
before it actually starts becoming
relatively challenging to start building
muscle again
and so that's the basic idea and what
they did in this article which was a
review article
is they pulled together all of the
animal and human studies
that basically examined myonuclear
content
after muscle atrophy to see whether
myonuclear permanence was a thing
and i'll note here that most of the
animal studies were longitudinal
so looking at changes in fiber size and
changes
in myonuclear density over time in the
same animal
most of the studies in humans are
cross-sectional so basically comparing
fiber size and myonuclear density in
young versus older
humans because humans live a lot longer
than mice and you don't necessarily want
to do a 50-year study
on the same topic and they also
discussed some
individual studies that were actually
relevant to kind of the whole concept of
muscle memory
so for example they looked at some
studies
where basically they looked at my
nuclear domain size at baseline and
looked to see if people with smaller
baseline myonuclear domains
did build muscle faster than people with
larger myonuclear domains because that
would be kind of conceptually similar to
having smaller myonuclear domains after
muscle atrophy
so basically studies that didn't
necessarily look at the entire
muscle memory model but but one
individual part of it
so there's there was a lot going on in
this review article
but but i'm going to keep this pretty
high level the big picture for my
nuclear permanence is that it seems that
myonuclei
are lost at a slower rate than muscle
atrophy
itself occurs but they're probably not
actually permanent
so for example if you take a few months
off training
and you lose a consider a considerable
amount of muscle mass
at that point all or most of your
myonuclei are probably still sticking
around
so you can you can regain the muscle you
lost pretty quickly
but if you take several years off of
training that that's probably long
enough to have lost
uh some of your myonuclei so you
probably wouldn't
be able to easily get all the way back
to where you'd been previously
um and it you know if you took
decades off of training you might be
essentially starting back from square
one
at least from a from a myonuclei
perspective
um there's also some evidence that the
rate
of myonuclei loss may be faster at
at greater ages so basically if uh
if you're me or trex or mike and we took
a year off training we'd probably be
fine whereas if helms took a year off
training he'd be in
uh in really tough [ __ ] um
and then from from a big picture for the
whole concept of myonuclei
mediated muscle memory a lot of that is
based on one study which
which very deservedly made waves because
uh
it tells a really clear story i would
say so there was a 2013 study by egner
and colleagues where essentially what
they did
is they had two groups of mice and they
implanted a
testosterone releasing pellet in half of
them
and in the other half they implanted a
sham pellet
for two weeks so they had those pellets
in for two weeks
they removed them and then they
basically had three weeks where nothing
was going on and they just monitored
them for those
uh three weeks and then they finished it
off with a two week period of
uh like overload-induced hypertrophy and
they induced that overload via synergist
ablation so they were looking
at a hypertrophy of the extensor
digitorum
longus in the mice and i think they they
removed part of
the mouse's soleus uh if memory served
so basically removing a synergist so
the muscle left is is just like
receiving more work
in kind of day-to-day mouse activities
and so what they saw is that during the
two weeks of testosterone administration
fiber size and myonucleic content
increased in the mice that were given
testosterone and obviously
nothing happened in the in the mice that
were given the sham pellet
during the three weeks off in the mice
previously given testosterone
muscle fiber size decreased to the point
that it was pretty comparable to the to
the mice that had been given a sham
pellet but myonuclear density remained
elevated it was maintained
uh in spite of the fact that muscle
fiber size was lost
and then during the two-week overload
period mice
previously given testosterone grew
approximately two-fold more than the
mice who had not
previously been given testosterone and
so
that that basically seems to to flesh
out the entire
um myonuclei mediated
muscle memory concept uh but one thing
to note about that study
is that it's hard to it's hard to
completely square
the difference in myonuclear density
between the two groups of mice with the
amount of overload-induced hypertrophy
at the end of the study so so this is a
direct quote
from my mass article following the three
weeks of muscle atrophy in the group of
mice that previously received
testosterone
their muscle fibers were the same size
as the mice that had
received the sham treatment and their
myonuclear density
uh myonuclei myonuclei per millimeter of
fiber length
was approximately 15 greater following
two weeks of overload fiber growth was
roughly two folds greater in the mice
that had previously received
testosterone
so just using rough numbers if a 15
greater
myonuclear density can increase
transcriptional capacity by 15
but you're attempting to explain a
roughly 100 difference in hypertrophy
some other mechanisms must be accounting
for the remaining 85
difference in hypertrophy thus retaining
myonuclei following atrophy may be a
mechanism of muscle memory but it can't
be the only mechanism
and it's likely to not be the most
important mechanism
so i i think that's uh that sums up the
muscle memory bit
pretty well so basically myonuclei do
seem to be lost at a slower rate
than just total muscle tissue but
they're probably not permanent
and i do think they do i do think they
likely contribute to muscle memory to
some degree but i don't think they are
the explanatory factor i think there's
probably something else or
uh probably more accurately multiple
other things going on
explaining the phenomenon of muscle
memory one that we know about
is epigenetic modification so there was
a study by
seabourn and colleagues that we've also
looked at in mass
that found some epigenetic changes
following
resistance training that were retained
upon d training
and probably contributed to increased
rates of hypertrophy
when people retrained so yeah you know
myonuclei may play a role
epigenetic modifications probably play a
role and there are probably other things
that we simply don't know about yet that
play a role but
i i do think the the whole concept of
myonuclei
mediated muscle memory uh
is probably a little bit too simplistic
and i think people might have a little
bit too much faith in it as
the one and only or even primary driving
calls
of the phenomenon of muscle memory would
you say that your perspective has
changed a lot
on myonuclear domain theory over the
last few years as as more of this
research has come out
i i would say so i i used to be a lot
more confident
in the whole concept of my nuclear
permanence
um so
there there had previously been some
studies looking at
uh say like spinal injury and found that
like oh
if you have extreme muscle atrophy
following spinal injury
some myonuclei were lost but all of the
stuff that i had seen basically looking
at
atrophy caused by inactivity tended to
show that my nuclei were
were retained pretty well so i think
just that area of research has
fleshed out quite a bit in recent years
and you know now we're seeing that
the concept of myonuclear permanence
even under like quote-unquote normal
circumstances
isn't quite as solid as we may have
previously thought it was
um and also like you know
now we know that epigenetics are
probably uh contributing to
to muscle memory as well uh and i'm just
less confident that
uh the myonuclei stuff is the driver
of the whole muscle memory concept like
i do still think it contributes but i
don't think it's
like the one and only or even the
primary explanatory factor
yeah i mean and we rarely see that right
in physiology where
where things are are quite that simple
where there's one single driver that
explains all of it
and i i think that kind of relates to
why the initial
uh concept was so appealing right it was
very tidy and clean and simplistic and
straightforward so
uh you know i was in the same boat i was
like cool the whole picture is explained
very concisely that sounds great to me
but it has gotten a little bit more
complicated as more of this research has
trickled out
that's something that gets repeated in
in science a lot not to be too meta
um it's what what daniel kahneman calls
what you see is all there is
uh the idea that when we have an
observed phenomenon but we don't have a
mechanism to understand it
once we get even a glimmer of a picture
of some something
it takes on far more weight than we have
evidence to justify
and i think um that's probably a good
reminder for anyone who
is reading some of these more i'm not
going to say fringe science because it
almost delegitimizes it but
i would say the edge of what's been
explored once we're trying to understand
unknown processes i think it's really
helpful just to remind ourselves we know
about maybe one-tenth
of all the different physiological
things that are going on
so you know anytime we think we
understand what's going on we need to
retain that level of uh speculativeness
that is appropriate
because it's easy to lump it all
together one example
and i'll shut up like be once we figured
out that there are different types of
fibers
and i we looked at this back in the 80s
and 90s we started attributing
a lot of things to type 1 and type 2
fibers
based on a very limited understanding of
them and saying oh this is the main
mechanism
before we understood about stiffness
before we understood
that just because there was a faster
contractile velocity doesn't mean that
force is actually higher per
per square unit of fiber etcetera
etcetera so anyway just a little aside
something i've been thinking about while
you're talking no i i agree
wholeheartedly and honestly uh
like i mentioned the clues were there in
the egner study itself
uh like there was a 15 difference in my
nuclear density
and a two-fold difference in hypertrophy
so unless
you're also proposing that if there is a
slight elevation in myonuclear density
the transcriptional capacity of those
myonuclei
also increases like six-fold uh it's
hard to completely bridge that gap you
know
um so like the uh uh
the ability to push back against this
concept was there in the data itself
um and i think like everyone just missed
it myself included like not throwing
shade at anyone i
definitely used to be way way too
confident in this concept
um but yeah i i think you're completely
right like we
we as a community observed uh muscle
memory
and uh i i also think like a lot of
people
were used to say like oh it's complete
bro science like we don't have evidence
to support this and then as soon as
there was a little shred of evidence
uh we wanted to say like yeah [ __ ] you
like
my observations weren't wrong this is a
real thing
now science proves it and here's exactly
what's going on like
you you want to have excessive
confidence
to be able to push back at people who
had previously been saying you were
wrong
uh and yeah i think a lot of people
myself included just got
a little bit too swept up in it now
helms what was that phrase that you used
there
what you see is all there is what you
see is all there is
so for my humble contribution to this
conversation
i want to talk about a few studies where
what you see
is not what it is okay so i i covered uh
a few meta-analyses in 2020. to me
2020 was the year of the meta-analysis
for for my mass writing there were quite
a few metas that i read
and basically reconstructed um so i did
a meta-analysis on
carnitine one on arginine and another
on vitamin d and i don't want to take up
too much time in this conversation
because i want to make sure we
really uh make use of our time with our
esteemed guests here but
the reason that i bring it up is for all
three of those meta-analyses
looking through it there were some
pretty straightforward uh
choices made in the analysis that that i
felt kind of undermined the results
uh so uh i don't want to be excessively
critical but but there are some things
that if you go by the book
they probably ought to have been handled
differently in order to have a more
robust calculation
involved in the meta-analysis so going
through them a few of the things that
really jumped out to me
double counting so using multiple data
points from the same study
without accounting for that or i should
say from the same participants right so
if one study is measuring the impact of
a supplement
and they measure bench press and it
works those participants contributed one
data point
their bench press results now if they
happen to measure bench press
and squat should that study have twice
as much
bearing on the overall results of the
meta-analysis
theoretically no you know we're
basically looking at the same
effect but counting it twice and so we
need to make sure we account for the
fact that that is just
one group of people who had a strength
increase in that study so double
counting
is when you're using multiple outcomes
from the same individual
and therefore you're giving those
individuals a little bit more influence
on the meta-analysis than they should
otherwise have
a couple other things that came up in
some of these is
not accounting for the effects of time
so if we're looking at something like
soreness
or a biomarker of muscle damage
and we're looking at it immediately
after exercise and then 24 and 48 and 72
and 96 hours later
we need to account for the fact that
those came from the same person
but we also need to account for the fact
that we do expect to change over time
you know
we can't treat those as if they're
equivalent data because they're not
right
so a soreness at baseline before
exercise is done it probably ought to be
zero and it probably shouldn't be too
variable
if everybody followed the pre-visit
instructions so uh
not accounting for those time effects
which can be done mathematically
another thing that came up is in some
instances
making the mistake of treating standard
errors
as if they're standard deviations and
vice versa
and that can have a remarkably huge
impact on the effect sizes that you see
in the study and so
there were quite a few meta-analyses i
reviewed where
they would say um like hey we were
looking at this body of literature and
we noticed that there was
extreme heterogeneity and wildly
asymmetrical
funnel plots anyway here's the results
like they didn't go forward and say like
okay well
why was there extreme heterogeneity and
why were the funnel plots
chaotically asymmetrical and in most of
the cases it's because it
one or two or three of the effect sizes
were calculated
using a standard error that was being
treated as a standard deviation
and so we saw these you know
astronomically huge effect sizes that
were getting lumped into the analysis
and really throwing off the actual
calculated effect size
and introducing all of these um you know
factors of funnel plot asymmetry and
heterogeneity
and and really undermining the the
robustness and legitimacy of the
pooled effect size that's calculated so
without getting super deep into the
details
you know i met i looked at a
meta-analysis on carnitine
in 2020 uh in one of our issues of mass
and my results uh after accounting for
some of those things the effect of time
and double counting and correlations
between repeated measures after
accounting for those things the results
were far different a number of p-values
changed from
significant to non-significant uh and it
really painted a different picture of
the results
uh same thing goes for the meta-analysis
about arginine
you know there were some some effect
sizes that were that were miscalculated
and uh for the arginine one no the
vitamin d1 i looked at
there was a pooled effect size of 2.14
as a cohen's d value that was
statistically non-significant
in a meta-analysis i mean anytime you
see that you got to look deeper and say
what
happened here so for the carnitine one
for the arginine one
and for the vitamin d1 after accounting
for some of these fundamental principles
of how these meta-analyses should be
conducted
the results changed in a meaningful way
the practical takeaways actually changed
from recalculating them
after accounting for some of those
really key considerations
in the analyses so my takeaway from this
was that after seeing i think it was
like three out of four metas that i
reviewed
where if you went back and crunched the
numbers with some of those factors
considered
the actual conclusion of the study
changed
my take-home point was unfortunately for
now i think
the hierarchy of evidence that has those
meta analyses perched at the top
i think that applies to sports nutrition
and exercise science in theory
but not necessarily in practice there
are far more meta analyses that i see
published in our area
that have objectively inverted
conclusions
uh and so that's not what we want to put
at the top of the hierarchy of evidence
and so
until we see a much more reliable
quality control mechanism
where we know that these are getting
reviewed thoroughly and that we're not
seeing these
pretty common errors sneaking into the
literature
you know in some fields you can wave
around a meta-analysis and say like
this is my trump card i win the argument
because i have a meta-analysis on my
side
i don't think we're there yet i think i
think we need a lot more
a lot more education and a little bit of
soul-searching when it comes to the
review process
of meta-analyses and a really easy way
to look at this
is uh you know zordos helms you guys
work
in academic departments how many people
in your hallway
if you just handed them a data set and
said make me a meta how many would feel
really really comfortable with that
some but not everybody certainly not
everybody
and i think the question then becomes
well who's who's reviewing all these
meta-analyses
because there's a lot and i know a lot
of researchers
but i don't know that many that could
construct a meta statistically
and so if those are the people reviewing
the metas if you can't
walk through the mechanics of how that
analysis works it's very difficult to
review it thoroughly
and so my my big takeaway from from uh
this year in mass just from the studies
i wrote is we got to be really careful
about metas we we have to review them
as thoroughly if not more thoroughly
than the individual studies that go into
them
if you've been noticing a lot more
reviewers asking
you to review papers a lot more you know
journals
that's because every time a
meta-analysis comes across my desk i i
put your name down
as and and rejected my own my own review
so
uh this is what you've created uh and i
and i hope you're willing to
to be the savior of us all for these
meta-analyses yeah i mean it's a sweet
it's a sweet gig like um that during
that time i i could be working on
other things that are fun or enjoyable
or compensated or compensated but it is
a compelling argument
to say why don't i put that stuff off
cancel that date with my girlfriend and
review this paper instead so
helms it's great to know that you're the
person that's uh
inundating my inbox with all those
requests i i appreciate it
tracks just just keep the note and you
can
um every time you review a meta don't
forget you should put it in the
service category so when you submit for
tenure and mass the committee will
review it
that's yeah i i will certainly remember
to do that
um how many years do i need for tenure
uh the
the committee hasn't decided yet it's
kind of open-ended typically
it's three or four um however the
committee
has left it open-ended based upon
when your work has reached the level
of perfection international recognition
in 107 countries
and every title is
has been ranked in the top five percent
of all mass titles so
you submit whenever you see fit but you
can only submit one time
and uh the committee will take it under
consideration it's really at our
discretion so
uh that's the vague criteria we we also
only have three spots
so you're you're probably going to have
to hold on until one of us dies well i
mean eric yeah so given the general
but look at but look at him given the
general trajectory of
helms and his his advanced age and also
how many hurricanes are currently
hitting
florida uh if you can hold on for three
years
you have a pretty good point now one
thing that's been helpful is i've been
doing a lot of self-sighting
in my own mass article so my ass index
is through the roof had we kept the ass
anybody listening i would say you could
thank me
but perhaps you you're on helm's
side on this going back to i don't know
january 2017 when helms came up with
this uh
research applications in strength sport
and
i said no because people could call us
our
ass and he said immediately
he immediately said i know that's the
point
so what i deemed as just something that
could not happen
he looked at as a benefit it's a it's a
feature not a bug mic
uh our ass is what we could have been
today
uh i actually forgot that was really the
one we had that conversation i remember
because i was very adamantly against
this
and and and i was very much on the side
of mass
and uh i would say to my surprise but
knowing you maybe not to my surprise
you were pushing back the other way and
i'm glad that i held strong but maybe
some some out there would have preferred
that helms would have won that argument
i would say probably the vast majority
of people yeah
well i tell you what guys we probably
only have time for one more here
and uh given that helms has so much uh
kind of as a consolation prize since he
wasn't able to name
the publication and he's been salty
about that for a few years i i think
it would be fair if we let him take the
last one here
well i'm sure we'll get mike back on the
podcast at some point but like really
how much more time does helms have left
that's this is like
you give him the keynote spot just as a
tip of the cap and say listen we
appreciate
the body of work the last few years
you've been slipping a little bit with
equality but
we still pay that respect you don't put
me on the panel you give me the keynote
because you don't want me answering
questions
you can treat this as as what you get
for your lifetime achievement award
yeah absolutely um so the reason that i
wanted to
save this one for last is because uh
this one was
more of a concept review and it's about
a topic that i think
everyone all of us have an interest in
and it's talking about progression
frameworks for hypertrophy
how to advance uh training over the
course of a mesocycle when hypertrophy
is the goal i know that
all of us have an interest in resistance
training programming so it's a really
nice
kind of round table approach to finish
things off here and this was also a
topic that generated a lot of
conversation in the evidence-based
fitness community
greg we kind of talked about this on the
on the podcast several episodes ago but
helms why don't you give us a little
rundown about this concept review
progression framework for hypertrophy
absolutely no i'm i uh
i appreciate this consolation prize i i
appreciate this this appointment as a
keynote
on a podcast um i don't really see my
career
advancing beyond this point so i'm just
going to apologies for that little intro
but i'm just kind of basking
so um people who are you know in in our
community are probably aware
of the numerous uh podcasts that both
myself mike israel tell brian miner
uh jared jarrett feather and some other
authors on two recent scj articles
um you know we've talked about it
outside of peer review
uh and there was also uh their
peer-reviewed article in in the most
recent scj and rlte
um but i you know the the one i wrote
for mass that came out this year
it almost stands to to to the side of
that whole conversation
because i've noticed independent of
whether you think
uh or or what time scale you want to
increase sets
over for hypertrophy i think it's really
important
important to understand volume for
hypertrophy
so that was my main motivation for
writing this article
um you know credit to stronger by
science
um and i'm forgetting the author but
greg could you remind me who
who's the author who wrote about the new
way of counting volume that you always
get misattributed
as the author of this but counting sets
for volume nathan jones
yes nathan jones wrote a fantastic
article
that i would say was ahead of its time
but an accurate representation
of the collective data we have on volume
for hypertrophy specifically
that said hey you know we maybe we
should be looking at at hard sets of a
reasonable repetition count
i'm not even sure if that reasonable
repetition count was
part of the equation yet but back in
either 2015 or 2016
i think 2015 actually this article came
out and basically
much like a systematic review listed all
of the time points
where a number of sets had a more
predictive relationship with which group
would hypertrophy more
than volume load so the conversation
about
volume changed fundamentally in our
community right around 2015
as a direct result of that article and
it shifted the conversation from being
about volume load
two being number of sets and this really
makes sense from kind of a henneman size
principle or
effective reps quote unquote framework
even though i know we've we've poked
some holes in the
i would say the rigidity of the
effective revs model but the idea that
if you do a set whether it's a set of 20
or a set of six
and you go to a reasonable proximity of
failure eventually
you get to the point where you're
recruiting the vast majority of fibers
in a muscle
and you produce a similar per set
stimulus for hypertrophy
so boom 2015 that happens conversation
changes
and now all of a sudden when you talk
about volume there's a large significant
number of people
who are taking that to mean set volume
and i think that's that's a good thing
if we're looking at it from the
perspective
of uh hypertrophy
however when that gets translated into
actually enforcing progressive overload
or or seeing progressive overload occur
it changes the conversation in a way
that is
potentially problematic and what i mean
by that is that if you simply use
a fixed number of sets and a fixed
program
but you were just to allow progressive
overload to take its course
and let's say a three by ten model on
any given lift as you get stronger while
you're training for hypertrophy
your volume load will increase because
three by ten times a hundred kilos is
going to produce less volume load
than three by ten times one or one or
five kilos
so you could have a program where you
had a fixed rpe target
and a fixed number of sets and you let
your your load expand and you would see
that volume load would go up
so the previous conversation was kind of
like hey you know if you're getting
stronger
your volume loads going up we know
volume load is is is the relationship
between hypertrophy and training that is
most
strong now that's not perfectly true but
it resulted in this mindset of
hey so long as i'm getting stronger
that's okay that's good
but then the conversation changed to
okay i need to be increasing volume
that's what's related to hypertrophy
and i saw a lot more people who were
increasing sets in a more
proactive fashion over the course of
either you know mesocycles or some other
time scale so kind of independent from
the idea of mesocycle
progression i think it's really
important to understand
that you can always increase sets the
only thing that is going to prevent you
from increasing number of sets you want
to do
is simply not having enough time so it's
very easy to expand
that variable to a point where it's
actually counterproductive
while it's very difficult if not
impossible to do that when you're
looking at just reps or load
because you are limited by your actual
ability to perform
so that sounds like just purely a
cautionary tale
but what i presented in this article was
that you can use those two things
in relationship to one another you can
establish a given set volume you think
is appropriate you think is
stimulative and then when you can no
longer meet your progressions over a
time
scale that's reasonable for your
training age and the conditions you're
in
hopefully not a diet for example
then you'd be able to see okay i can no
longer progress
and you can assess your level of
recovery and from that point you can
then make a decision
to increase set volume so one informs
the other
and they have to be seen as distinct
types of volume
seeing volume load go up is an
indication progressive overload is
occurring
when volume load is no longer going up
that's an indication you should perhaps
do something and if your goals are
hypertrophy
you know lifting heavier for a set of
eight is not directly stimulative
of hypertrophy it's indicative of an
overload
so that's kind of where that that
algebra changes a little bit and i think
it's mostly a useful concept piece
because hopefully
it changes the conceptual way people
look at programming for hypertrophy
to see true volume increases in number
of sets
as a pathway to stimulating further
growth when you see a plateau
in in volume load which is increasing
via reps or load on the bar depending on
how you're progressing whether that's
increasing sets or sorry reps to a point
then increasing load
or keeping reps fixed and increasing
load a lot of the various progression
metrics we had before
you know thinking of a set advancement
as a volume increase
so that was the purpose of the paper
i really do think it stands aside from
the discussion of whether
a mesocycle is a reasonable time course
to increase number of sets or how
aggressively that should be done
that you might have heard between myself
and dr israetel
and brian miner and jared feather i
think that's a really cool discussion
but i think the gold in this article in
my opinion
is just having that understanding of the
difference between volume load and set
volume and understanding how they can
work together
to inform you on when you should make an
increase in set volume
yeah i mean one of the things i really
like about the way you talk about this
concept
is using your performance
um when it comes to you know looking at
the load used and the reps
successfully performed and even the reps
in reserve set to set and really using
that as
valuable information for kind of
steering the ship
as you go forward i know the way you
speak about it really resonates
with me because that's really how i do a
lot of my programming with with clients
um
and sometimes i have to tell people like
don't go into the gym
you know you've got your loads listed
you've got your sets and reps and
and you know what weight you're using
don't go in there and give me a heroic
effort and somehow overcome the odds and
outperform your capability here like
i'm just trying to learn from how we're
doing here you know so so
seeing that as valuable feedback to
dictate the next move i think is
extremely valuable
um and i always tell my clients like i
just want consistency go in give me what
you got tell me how many reps were left
in the tank and we'll adjust from there
and you know yeah sometimes you know
based on the numbers we're seeing it's
like hey
we're really not able to bump these
loads much week over week
are we doing too much are we doing too
little do we need a deload and
sometimes you increase set sometimes you
reduce them sometimes you go to a
different set rep scheme
you know but but the feedback component
is so important
and that's what's really valuable about
making those little incremental changes
you know just by bumping those loads up
week over week
is that like the standard approach that
you take i think you mentioned
in in your in the publication exchanges
um
doing kind of like a a double
progression method is that accurate
yeah that that's kind of uh that was no
to be clear you know brian miner
lead author on that one so he had a more
dominant role in writing it
and so some of uh what one contribution
that i really appreciated was that we
didn't just write the lte
to say hey there's problems with this
paper catch you later because this is
the strength conditioning journal
it's written you know mostly for
practitioners it's not jscr it has a
slightly different focus
it's predominantly articles written
about what you should do in practice
we wanted to finish it off with hey
here's a model that might
might make a little more sense given our
criticisms
and brian really wrote that section and
uh he uses what's called an auto
regulated double progression model
so real quickly for those who don't know
double progression is simply the idea
of not changing the load uh until you
reach a certain rep target on all your
sets so let's say for example
three by eight to twelve once you take
your eight rm
or your eight rep load or whatever rpe
and you get the three sets of 12
at that rm or rpe then you're allowed
quote unquote to increase load and you
go again right
now you can also throw an rpe
or a rep range into that so that you
kind of hang around a specific rpe
and once you can get a fixed number of
reps at an rpe
that's when you go up so now you're not
because the criticism of double
progression is that it basically leads
everyone to eventually
crushing themselves to get those three
by twelves right uh your
the first one might be worse form i got
my 12 the next one's a 10 rpe
the next one you may or may not have
actually done
the target exercise to get that set of
12 and then you get to go up and load
and then it doesn't go well at all
now you've gone up and load especially
given the exercises and if it's
dumbbells
you got to make sometimes a 10 jump and
load and and now you're barely even
reaching that eight rep target
so to get around that and to make it a
little more auto regulated
throwing in the rpe component can give
that indication like look we're not
after performance at all costs we're
trying to match the pace of adaptation
and that was brian's you know addition
to that i really like that
as far as how i roll with it i think
philosophically i'm 100 in line with
what you said eric
i will trade theoretical optimality
for more diagnostic clarity every time
that is something when i was purely an
athlete i made it i made an error all
the time with you know i would take the
quote unquote shotgun approach
you know i heard this is good i heard
this is good i heard this is good i
heard this is good i've read
way too much research i'm following way
too many people i'm going to do all the
things that should optimize progress
and then when it does or doesn't work i
have no idea why
i took a new supplement i followed a new
program i
increased number of sets every week i
also advanced my rpe
and i also have a linear progression of
reps and loads so my
reps are going down my rpe is going up
my sets are going up and i think that's
actually a very normal way for people to
train
you know they go from eight seven six if
they have a strength interest
their load is going up their rpe is
going up and they progress
sets how do you know what actually
worked or didn't work and just to give a
little bit of
uh i guess anecdotal name credibility
behind this
um i i'm not the only coach who's gone
more and more towards the direction of
diagnostic clarity
and also even at a very high level so to
drop another mic
mike tousheer if you watch kind of the
progression of his career and he's
i would say one of the more respected
thinkers in the
kind of applied uh you know world of
powerlifting he he works with many
high-level ipf lifters
who are already world-class elite
lifters in their right and is helping
them get better
that's hard to do um you know making
someone who already has a 500 wilks get
to a 550 wilks
that's something you don't sneeze at you
know and
he has gone i would say more extreme
than i am on this on this kind of uh
spectrum
uh he takes a microcycle leaves it fixed
and just allows load to go
up while meeting meeting a certain
target rpe
and then he will look at which
components when he does make a change
and only makes one change at a time
led to a reliable increase in in
strength in 1rm
and then he will see the time to peak
for the individual athlete
and use those to to help his athletes
get better so i think
philosophically i think it makes a lot
of sense especially when you get to the
point where additional adaptations are
very difficult to achieve you know if
you're working with let's say
high-level drug-free bodybuilders or
high-level drug-free power lifters
that you really want to be able to know
if what you did did something
beneficial or harmful and that means
you want to be very careful when you add
complexity to a program that complexity
better be worth it in my opinion you
know one thing that
i'd like to add here to a discussion
that i've enjoyed listening to
is that for everybody out there when it
comes to
data and science on programming for
lifting weights
you know i used to say it's science but
it's not an exact science but i think
it's
even even more elementary than that it's
kind of a science like if you
if we go through a supplement study
we're going to understand the
proposed physiological mechanism of that
supplement
then we can debate if it increased reps
perform to failure if we think that's
meaningful for hypertrophy or not
but we understand the mechanism of why
that might work
when we consider all of these different
programming options
and you know eric you you mentioned the
the double progression model and i i
wasn't familiar with the terminology but
i uh gave those exact recommendations in
some of the low progression
uh videos they did for mass along with a
lot of other things and it made me think
that
you know what some of those videos did
and some of the article i wrote for for
greg's site a few years back
[Music]
is that we're just coming up with
metrics
that when we hit those targets we can
then make some sort of change
so all we know from science is that
that's a good idea so what
mike to share is doing is probably even
more scientific than trying to implement
every single scientific principle under
the sun
because in no study have we actually
shown all of those
scientific principles together to
actually work
aside from the fact as a coach or a
programmer you're handicapping yourself
by trying to implement all these things
at one time and then you implement
none of them by trying to do all of them
and so what mike t
is doing from what you're suggesting
he's looking and saying okay what's
causing this change
so he's trying to actually be more
scientific than some of the scientists
by saying all right we understand that
you need to make a change that you need
to overload somehow something needs to
be different
but i want to figure out what's doing
this and i understand
that it happens different things are
responsible for that on the individual
level
so i'm not going to treat every person
the same because if we go in this study
and i thought of this earlier too we
were talking about something else but
um it was on the refeed study when you
know trucks brought up the point how
how big did you want the effect to be in
a training study do you know how hard it
is to get significance when you have
eight people in one group and eight
people in another group and you change
one
periodization or progression variable or
whatever it is
oftentimes if you see i i i if you see a
significant difference i wouldn't be
surprised if that difference is by
chance at all
just because you have these individuals
that are in the study
that have you know very different
they're very different things could
cause
different changes for them so i really
like what you talked about what mike t
is doing and all we're doing is is
looking for okay once we hit more reps
now we can have more weight maybe it's
once we hit more reps
now we can add more sets we did three
sets of eight at a nine rp
once we get that three sets of eight
down to an average of a seven rp
now we can go ahead and add more weight
to that or once we hit three sets of
eight down at a seven rp
now we do three sets of nine that's a
similar concept as well and if you're
training for a hypertrophy for muscle
growth purposes
for bodybuilding i should say the the
cool thing about that is
it's a it's a much more forgiving method
of training than training for strength
whereas if you're training for you know
it's different i don't want that to
sound like it's easier because it's not
um that would be a very big misnomer to
take from that
um but it's more forgiving in the sense
that hey you missed a rap or you did
another rep no big deal
you needed to you're in a different gym
and you had to switch this exercise
today no big deal
but if you're getting ready for power
lift you me you got a squat you got a
bench press
if you overshoot the nine nine and a
half rp and you fail on a set
and you have a meet next week that's not
a good idea but for bodybuilding
you can put all of these different
metrics into play and find out what
works for you so to me it always goes
back so if you understand this
concept of once you hit this metric now
you can progress this thing
maybe for you it's session rp i notice
once my session rps tend to go down i'm
feeling more refreshed and then i add a
set
uh to that into that next session and
then i feel good but then people always
take this to say i have to add a set
i got to add the set on the squat you
can add the set on the leg extension
it doesn't have to be the main lift
every time and progress some volume in
other ways so
you have metrics whether it's hitting a
target number of reps and adding another
set hitting a target number of reps
adding uh more load for that hitting a
target number of reps and then adding
more reps
you know whatever it might be you can
make these changes but if you understand
those concepts i would challenge
everybody to think about
all of these other different ways that
we haven't even talked about
metrics that you can measure that might
be more specific to you
to be able to make to make these
adjustments in progress going forward so
it's just to say that
eric wait the roundabout way saying what
you brought up about mike t
one it's so much credit to him for
everything he's done for the community
over the years
and then i view that as kind of the
ultimate scientific approach
rather than what we try to sometimes do
as scientists which i think is uh
kind of the irony of the whole thing and
credit to mike
yeah i mean it really comes down to are
you applying the scientific findings or
applying the scientific method
and i feel like his approach is applying
the scientific method
which is actually uh you know for for
his needs
uh you know he's making his changes
based on scientific findings but that
scientific method that methodical
approach to
manipulating that variables helps him
really hone in on it on exactly what is
what is actually causing some of these
changes so you know
that diagnostic benefit of trying to
minimize the number of moving parts
at any given time is just extremely
extremely valuable
so i think that actually wraps up our
discussion here greg and i
very much appreciate the the other half
of the mass
research review team for joining us mike
helms thanks so much
for uh taking time with us today true
pleasure
yeah thanks to you guys we really
appreciate it in addition to our special
guest we'd also like to thank all of the
listeners
for joining us for this special episode
of the podcast
as i mentioned at the beginning of the
show we are currently running our
biggest mass sale of the year
with a huge portion of the proceeds
going to the american foundation for
suicide prevention
if you want to take advantage of the
sale be sure to subscribe before it ends
on november 30th
thank you for joining us happy
thanksgiving to those who celebrate it
and we hope you enjoyed the show we will
be back with another episode
in two weeks thank you for listening to
the stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you